et pour en parler avec nous thomas forêt
fondateur du réseau social alternatif
waller et secrétaire générale
d'opération lancelot association pour la
souveraineté numérique bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors d'abord dites nous que pensez-vous
de la reconnaissance faciale vous êtes
pour ou contre
alors la reconnaissance faciale je suis
ni pour ni contre
c'est une technologie qui est
aujourd'hui existe et qui se développe à
vitesse grand v et qui permet
d'authentifier donc des personnes qui
sont prises en photos ou filmer alors
pourquoi je suis ni pour ni contre
parce qu'on peut pas être pour ou contre
une technologie qui va servir à des
usages différents
vous savez que la reconnaissance faciale
c'est déjà utilisé aujourd'hui quand
vous passez une frontière par exemple
donc c'est très bien ça permet
d'authentifier que la personne qui se
présente avec un passeport est bien la
bonne personne donc ça c'est une très
bonne chose et je suis contre évidemment
le déploiement de la reconnaissance
faciale en masse parce que ce serait
suivre nos faits et gestes le fait les
faits et gestes de nos concitoyens sans
leur consentement ça je suis content
il ya un réel risque d'atteinte aux
libertés individuelles en cas de
mauvaises encadrement bien sûr si ça
n'est pas un encadré ce sera nous
subirons le déploiement de ces
technologies est évidemment comme on le
voit par exemple sur la captation des
données personnelles c'est un sujet très
proche où on a plus aucune maîtrise et
bien si on encadre pas ddd puissance
financière des puissances d'état
pourront s'en servir comme par exemple
en chine où vous savez qu'il ya des
expérimentations qui s'en fait afin de
suivre les faits et gestes des des
citoyens et même de de noter leurs
mauvaises actions évidemment je pense
que ça c'est pas du tout le modèle de
société que ma vision alors justement le
secrétaire d'état au numérique 1 l'a dit
ce sont ces propos la france n'ira
jamais vers l'exemple chinois ou les
algorithmes de reconnaissance faciale
permettent de reconnaître partout
tout le monde dans la rue ça c'est un
extrême a absolument pas suivre un
exemple à ne pas suivre est ce qu'on
peut le croire c'est très coquin tu en
as on peut le croire bien sûr on peut
croire sa bonne volonté mais il faut ça
que cédric coll gouvernement que nous
avons actuellement
peut-être que dans cinquante ans ou même
20 ans sera plus où la même chose on
sait pas ce que ce que deviendront nos
démocraties il faut les bâtir et je
crois que bien sûr la bonne volonté du
gouvernement sur ce sujet n'est pas à
remettre en cause évidemment ne veut pas
une société de surveillance de masse
mais vous savez il y a quand même
toujours cette ce contre pouvoir aussi
qui est l'idée de la sécurité évidemment
il faut sécuriser nos espaces en
particulier en europe où les frontières
sont sont ouvertes et où on voit qu'on
peut on pourrait faire diminuer la
délinquance diminue et le terrorisme
évidemment avec ces technologies donc
c'est un vrai débat est ce que je pense
sur le fond c'est qu'il faut porter ce
débat
comme vous le faites auprès du public
auprès des citoyens et c'est ce que
propose cédric haut c'est à dire de
lancer des expérimentations limiter ses
rangs ce mot qui me paraît important
avec le consentement de ceux qui
participeront à ces expérimentations
pour ouvrir un débat moratoire et ça
c'est quand même ce qu'il faut faire il
faut porter ça devant la démocratie et
ne pas ne pas imposer des lois en douce
ou voiliers mais comment ça peut se
passer concrètement vous dites avec
l'autorisation de certains mais c'est à
dire alors danse dans le cadre de ces
expérimentations
ça peut être simple d'obtenir un
consentement avant imaginons une
expérimentation je ne sais pas dans un
dans un lycée par exemple ou même ou
dans une école peu importe où tout le
monde devra apporter son consentement
encore que le sujet des écoles des
lycées c'est le sujet des mineurs aussi
des enfants qu'il faut protéger
particulièrement donc ce n'est pas très
simple mais on peut obtenir un
consentement sur un périmètre délimité
maintenant là la reconnaissance faciale
si elle est déployée dans l'espace
public ce qui n'est pas le cas pour ses
expérimentations là le consentement est
impossible à obtenir la reconnaissance
faciale c'est quoi c'est une progression
en amélioration de 2 du dispositif de
caméra qu'on peut retrouver dans
certaines villes en france puis la
caméra c'est la captation de l'image est
là
les algorithmes qui derrière interprète
ces images peuvent reconnaître donc des
visages est associée une identité un
visage donc c'est tous les algorithmes
qui a derrière l'exploitation des images
et c'est ça la reconnaissance faciale
on peut la distinguait aussi d'autres
algorithmes depuis qu'ils peuvent être
couplés puisque il existe d'ores et déjà
par exemple des algorithmes qui
permettent de mesurer une émotion sur un
visage qui permettent de d'analyser un
comportement des foules
tout ceci cumulé peut évidemment faire
naître des systèmes de surveillance très
intelligent très puissant et si vous
étaient déployées à grande échelle très
dangereux pour nos libertés
individuelles
ça sera le mot de la fin thomas fort et
merci d'avoir répondu à merci à vous je
rappelle que vous êtes fondateur du
réseau social alternatif waller et
secrétaire générale d'opération lancelot
association pour la souveraineté
numérique
merci